The A to Z of isms... Libertarianism.
ů the words of the then US President
Ronald Reagan back in 1986.
Reagan's mockery of the
very government he headed
tapped into widespread American
support for a political philosophy
that grew throughout
the 20th Century.
Its most vocal champions
such as Senator Rand Paul
and the Koch brothers,
are on the political fringes.
But libertarian thinking has
influenced mainstream politics,
from Ronald Reagan's
attacks on government
to Margaret Thatcher's desire to...
Libertarianism's roots
go back much further though.
As their name suggests,
libertarians see their philosophy
as embodying the principles
of individual liberty,
promoted by the
European Enlightenment
and American independence
in the 18th Century.
Political libertarianism is
particularly at home in the USA,
which celebrates the pioneer values
of self-reliance and
rugged individualism.
Key among these
is the principle of self-ownership.
Your life belongs to you
and no-one else.
Hence, the liberty they defend
is what philosopher
Isaiah Berlin called...
ů especially governments.
Libertarians regard all government
as a necessary evil.
They favour a minimal state,
which the leading libertarian
philosopher Robert Nozick said,
should be...
Such a minimal state would not
even provide public services
such as health and education.
For libertarians,
welfare states create dependency
and stifle initiative.
These principles make libertarians
very critical of taxation.
Nozick went so far as to say that...
Although libertarians tend
to be politically right-wing,
there is also a fairly strong
tradition of left libertarianism,
such as that advocated by Canadian
philosopher Hillel Steiner.
He claims that no-one has a right to
claim ownership of common goods,
such as land.
With an equal distribution
of natural resources for everyone
there would be sufficient equality,
while leaving people
as free as possible
to decide how to live
their own lives.
Critics of libertarianism argue
that we are not truly free
unless we have access to things
like decent housing,
healthcare and education.
But we could only have this positive
freedom, as Berlin called it,
in a state that provides services
and redistributes some wealth.
Libertarianism may not be
well-known as a philosophy,
but its spirit is invoked every time
people attack "big government"
or "the nanny state".
It's probably the most
influential political philosophy
most people have never heard of.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)